あのこの人に1万円を送りたいんですが
かしこまりました850円になります先ほど atm でやろうとしたんですけど
メンギが多すぎてちょっと一平850円ですか合いそうですあの国際送金じゃなくて
普通の国内の振り込みです
他校宛の振込は850ようになりますちょっと待ってくださいそれならいい
tm でもう1回やってみます申し訳ございません350円の差は大きいですもんね
はいかなり酔って atm でも500円も書かれてことですかはいそうですならば
このどんな in バンキングってやつで送りますそれなら300円ですよね
はいよかったそれでも高い結構ただしオンラインバンキングの初期設定
は1000円がかかりますあと保証人の印鑑も必要になりますので直接 atm から
お金をおろす友達に渡しますのでかしこまりましたただし銀行はもう閉まっちゃいます
ので引き出しは150円がかかりますはい走ったら間に合うかもしれませんがすみませ
んもう1回確認させてください同じ日本に住んでいる友達に1万円を
来るのに850円がかかりますはいで窓口じゃなくて atn で送ったら
500円がかかりますはいそうですそしてご g 子だったらこの銀行の atm を
使っても引き出しは150円がかかり
そうですすいませんこの銀行の金利っていくらでしたっけ
0.001%です0.001%オンラインバンキングの早期設定を行って頂きますと
0.002に上がりますあすいませんこの銀行を使おうとお金がどんどん出て行って
しまいそうなので講座を投じさせてもらいますご迷惑をかけてしまいまして申し訳
ございませんでした
それでは2500円の解約金をとしてからすぐに当時ますねはい分かりべっ
me